Let's consider the motion
of a single particle
moving with a velocity v in a
ground reference frame, say.
Recall that we defined the
momentum of this object as mv.
And we know that
Newton's second law
can be written in terms of
the change of momentum dp/dt.
And when we integrated
Newton's second law,
for impulse causes
the integral of ADP
from some time t prime
equals 0 to some time t.
So we're integrating t prime.
And here, we're
taking your momentum
from some initial momentum
to some momentum at time t.
We have that the impulse
causes the momentum
of this single
particle to change.
And in particular, this
is what we call impulse.
And if the impulse is 0--
so as an example, if the
impulse fdt prime equals 0,
that tells us that the
momentum of our particle
has not changed.
Now, let's consider our same
thing for angular momentum.
The only difference is that
we choose some point s.
And we'll write the vector
rs to where the object is.
And our angular momentum
we defined about the point
s was the vector from s.
And we can indicate
maybe to the mass m.
So it's a vector from s to where
the object is located cross
the momentum of the object.
And this is how we define
the angular momentum.
And recall that
our basic concept
is that the torque about
s causes the angular
momentum about s to change
for this single particle.
Now, torque is if there's a
force acting on the particle.
So for instance, if the force
were acting at some angle.
Not only does the force change
cause the momentum to change,
but we know that if
there's a torque about s,
it will cause the angular
momentum of the particle
to change too.
Now, let's talk about
the angular impulse,
which is integrating
the torque from
say some time t prime
equals 0 to some time t.
And that's the integral of
the angular momentum about s.
And now we're integrating
this from some initial angular
momentum to some final
angular momentum.
And just as before, we have
that the angular impulse
will result in a change
of angular momentum.
And in particular, if
our angular impulse is 0,
that implies that the angular
momentum of this particle
is constant.
And so you can
see the analogies.
The important fact to realize
is that in the reference frame,
momentum does not
depend on any point,
but our angular
momentum does depend
on the choice of the point s.
And in particular, in terms of
the impulse, the torque about s
is also a quantity
that depends on s.
And so that's the
analogy between momentum
of a single particle and angular
momentum of a single particle.